have i just made a cheesy youtube video
telling you that you can make your own
iphone device for cheaper well no you
see knowing the cost of manufacturing
iphones will help you to understand not
just the current iphone prices but also
other key decisions being made like
their subscription plans and new apple
devices let's find out how cost overview
iphone boasts a 22 global smartphone
market share when you look at revenues
and profits from smartphones including
other companies like samsung and xiaomi
apple collects over 40 of all global
smartphone revenue and 75 of the
industry's profits making iphone the
world's most profitable phone and such
large profits are only possible through
a sizeable markup on its phones for
example according to tech insights tear
down analysis a brand new 256 gigabyte
storage iphone 13 pro costs around 570
to build while the retail price is a lot
higher than this at 1099
that's almost double but to be honest
this figure is somewhat misleading the
cost of materials is only one part of
what goes into the final retail price of
an iphone other costs include research
and development marketing shipping and
business overheads such as salaries and
administrative expenses when you add up
all of those costs the total cost would
be a lot higher than the amount
mentioned earlier so let's dive a little
deeper and focus on the breakdown of the
bill of materials first and then i will
give you a sense of how the other costs
factor into the overall cost of an
iphone and apple's overall profit
margins breakdown of manufacturing costs
apple uses a wide range of materials and
hardware to build its products the
iphone alone is made of metal glass and
many other components such as the
battery sensors modems and circuit
boards so let's break down the cost of
each such element and estimate the
manufacturing cost of the latest iphone
13 pro let's begin by looking at the
critical components that makes an iphone
work its processor or what's commonly
known as the brain of the phone apple
relies on chipmaker tsmc to produce the
a series chips that power its iphones
the latest iphone models use the a15
bionic chip built using tsmc's second
generation 5 nanometers fabrication
process the a15 bionic chip contains 15
billion transistors and is one of the
most complex chips ever created it's
also one of the single most expensive
components of the phone it's tough to
gauge the actual manufacturing price of
such a chip since many fixed costs are
involved like r d testing and materials
but most estimates suggest that the new
iphone a15 bionic chip costs upwards of
120 adding other components to the
chipset like storage of 256 gigabytes a
memory of one terabyte a modem for
communications and other circuitry of
the soc or system on a chip the total
cost of the iphone 13 pro processor is
around 200 in addition to the processor
other vital components that make up an
iphone are its display camera system
battery sensors and housing unit these
components make up the next big chunk of
the iphone's manufacturing costs so let
me put a number to these components and
see where our total stands after that
china's boe technology group
manufactures the iphone 13 pro's newest
super retina xdr oled display apple is
looking to shift from boe and
considering the purchase of lg displays
which will make manufacturing costs of
these displays even cheaper in the
future iphones but for now i'm looking
at a unit price of around 75 for each
display panel next are the cameras the
iphone 13 pro's triple unit camera
system is one of the best smartphone
cameras out there in the market today
while other smartphone manufacturers
have experimented with larger megapixel
counts for their camera systems apple
has maintained its 12 megapixel camera
core and focused on the lens and
software side currently all iphone
camera sensors are sourced from sony
however apple is looking to develop its
in-house camera manufacturing
capabilities in the future based on
expert reports i'll peg the new phone's
four cameras front and back at 95
next is the battery which is a highly
efficient 3095 milliamp unit apple
claims to have reduced the overall cost
of its batteries however most experts
agree that the battery cost has remained
the same in the last few models so going
by that the battery cost for the new
iphone 13 pro should not exceed 15 per
unit and finally we have the various
sensors housing units and other
miscellaneous hardware items again it is
hard to put a number to this still after
researching multiple documents and
looking at the breakdowns of older
iphone models i can safely assume that
the total cost of this segment should be
around 60 dollars so that brings the
overall cost of all the materials that
go into manufacturing the new iphone 13
pro to 445
assembled in low labor cost china but
that's not the end of the story once
apple has all of the materials it needs
to assemble them into a final product
this is where another significant chunk
of the cost of an iphone comes from
manufacturing an iphone is a highly
complex and expensive process it
involves hundreds of individual steps
and dozens of manufacturing facilities
mainly in china to start apple uses a
process called surface mount technology
to attach all of the tiny components
onto the circuit boards this process is
typically done by automated machines
although some manual labor is still
involved apple prefers to undertake all
its assembly operations in china not
because it is a source of cheap labor as
many of us believe according to tim cook
china stopped being the source of cheap
labor years ago when they started moving
up in the value chain it is now a place
where a large number of excellent
tooling engineers reside and they are
vital to the iphone's delicate assembly
operations after the surface mounting
process is complete the circuit boards
are then sent to another facility to be
tested and assembled into the final
product this process includes attaching
things like the camera the display and
battery finally the iphone undergoes a
series of quality control tests before
it's packaged up and shipped off to
apple stores and retailers worldwide
after reviewing the labor costs involved
in the assembly process and the
financial sheets of the two companies
that undertake this process for apple
foxconn and pegatron i have estimated
that it costs apple around 100 to
assemble a single iphone this puts my
final cost of manufacturing the new
iphone 13 pro at 545
let's round that off to 550. you can be
confident of this estimate since this is
only 20 off from the estimates put out
by tech insights they obviously used a
more scientific method so why is apple
charging you 1099
for the phone where does the other 550
go is it all profits for apple or are
there additional costs involved total
costs of an iphone
of course it's important to remember
that the manufacturing cost is just a
part of what it takes to bring an iphone
to the market 550 is just the raw cost
of making the phone other costs are
involved such as research and
development marketing business overheads
like logistics and shipping salaries and
administrative expenses the list goes on
apple is one of the largest companies
globally it takes a lot of different
expenses to keep the business going so
when estimating the costs beyond the
simple manufacturing costs i focused on
three major components r d expenses
sales related fees and marketing
expenses according to its recent
financial reports for the 12 months
ending march 31st 2022 apple's research
and development expenses were 24 billion
that's about 14 of its total profits for
the same year if i were to simply add
that 14 extra cost to my manufacturing
cost of 550 it would now be around 630
according to the same reports another 14
of its gross profit was spent on sales
and general administrative expenses this
increases the overall cost yet again to
705
finally let's assume that apple spends
about 50 dollars per iphone on its
marketing expenses when you add all of
these three costs up a good case can be
made that the total cost of an iphone 13
pro can be in the ballpark of 750 to 800
per unit so there you have it that's how
much it actually costs to make an iphone
so it's safe to say that apple is making
a healthy profit on each iphone sale
after all they are one of the most
profitable companies globally and with
new innovations and improvements coming
out every year it doesn't look like
they'll be slowing down anytime soon
what happens when innovation peaks but
even if innovation does peak apple may
have already sorted it all out at the
end of april 2022 mkbhd asked the
question in his youtube video what
happens when the iphone peaks that is
what happens when people have no need to
buy newer iphones year in and year out
because the features of older models are
so similar and the answer is it's
already happened in the closing of 2018
apple lost a good chunk of its net worth
due to people buying fewer and fewer
iphones this trend has seen apple
innovate around the iphone in the sense
of innovating subscription services for
users of the device my previous video on
apple's subscription model for newer
iphones also highlights this new trend
recently tim cook's appearance at the
oscars albeit overshadowed by the slap
that was heard around the globe didn't
go unnoticed as he showed support for
apple tv originals that were nominated
other renovations include airpods apple
watch and more and my previous video on
apple's upcoming innovations for the
century shed more light on this too one
of those new innovations apple glasses
are expected to be released with the
iphone 14 lineup later in 2022 as the
iphone 14 devices are rumored to have
wi-fi 6e connectivity standard great for
connecting with the mixed reality
glasses this new model of innovating
around the device is great since it
means that apple doesn't have to build
as many devices every year hence less
waste and it still doesn't stop profits
coming in elsewhere from other
subscriptions and newer devices so the
next time you're tempted by an expensive
new iphone just remember that apple has
likely already made back its investment
many times over and suppose you can't
afford the latest model in that case
there's always the option of buying a
used phone at a fraction of the original
price if you'd like to learn more about
other tech topics like this one be sure
to click on any one of the cards in this
video thanks for watching